hello everyone welcome to my first
episode what is this call tales from
Stardust Stardust reactions interactions
with me I don't know what I'm gonna call
it yet you know what I'm gonna call it
cuz obviously by the time you see this
it'll be up but basically in my last
tales from the comments section video I
said I'd do some Stardust interactions
kind of in the vein of that and then of
my Black Panther spoiler talk I said hey
this is the one so do your Black Panther
reactions on Stardust tag me and then
then I'll pick and choose some and then
react to those in this digital
Wonderland it'll be like an interaction
but not actually an interaction with the
power of editing it is an interaction
whatever I'm lonely so these are some of
your Stardust reactions I'm gonna get
into them in a second some disclaimers
one this does contain some spoilers so
if you haven't seen Black Panther yet
it's gonna spoil then a couple weeks
that's enough time and - I actually had
a lot of people submit so if you did
submit one you don't see it here safe to
say to a degree I understand what the
judges on America's Got Talent feel like
really hard to whittle down like that
just it and most importantly please keep
in mind these reactions are people who
came out to play they came to have fun
now that I'm saying the YouTube comments
section is by default of venomous talk
successful don't you say it can be so if
you're gonna be like a consider
them off-limits just don't be a dick I'm
saying so let's just get into it
Stratis reactions this one first could
not get enough of latisha right as
Sheree in black panther she's the scene
stealer she's intelligent
adorable charismatic she is the cue to
two challahs double-oh-seven
and all I kept thinking every time I'm
watching her is man I would love to see
her in a room with Tony Stark with
Robert Downey jr. and he's under
estimating her and she's like all right
listen old dude I got some tricks up my
sleeve and you're gonna find out do you
think we'll see something like that in
infinity war thank you for the reaction
man definitely on the same page with
Sheree myself a crush going on with her
yes I find intelligent women attractive
try not to faint
but I do agree their scenario begs
itself to happen to tech geniuses in the
same room together that needs to happen
every bit as much as Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner had to be in a room
together for Avengers like they have to
be in a room together somehow all that's
gonna happen in infinity war I don't
know if I'll have time but a genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist in a
room with genius confident royalty
come on Pepper Potts did make an honest
man at a Tony Stark if that had not
happened maybe a little more interesting
I still want to say I just saw a black
panther I thought it was really great
especially because I feel longer he was
really awesome as a villain cuz like he
made people question their values and
how they run Wakanda I didn't notice
that he's kind of just a typical Marvel
villain of that just the evil version of
the
I was wondering if you agree that they
actually worked in that movie or if
you're actually kind of sick of them
keeping doing this but I thought it
worked really well
yeah I do see that a lot there are a lot
of Marvel movies or even comic-book
movies in general where it's like you
have the hero and then the villain is
ultimately a bad version of the hero in
terms of tech or superpowers Ironman did
that Doctor Strange did that - America
Winter Soldier with Bucky they did that
Superman Zod Green Lantern Sinestro but
for me what makes the villain isn't
really their suit or their tax it's
their ideology I like the ideology that
conflicts with the heroes ideology
that's where I'm interested if you look
at kill monger he's only ever a black
panther opposite at the very end like
the last part of the last act of the
movie that he's a dude who's like hey
you're not doing a good enough job I'm
gonna get you done and that's where kill
monger is interesting they only put him
in a cat suit for the same reason anyone
ever puts the villain in a suit or gives
them abilities that can rival the heroes
so we can have a big beefy fight at the
end of the movie pretty good the pacing
suffered a little bit and also suffered
from that classic Marvel humor which I
don't mind but I wish they would stop
putting it in serious scenes because it
totally takes away the effect they have
also kill monger was a great bill and I
think he's one of the standouts for
Marvel finally they get away from the
generic kind of ones usually have and
also do you think that Black Panther
will die with T'Challa since they burned
all the flowers to give them as power
stickin to the end part of that reaction
because that's what grabbed me that is a
fair point if they burned all the
flowers that makes the black plant
that's a fair point if they burned all
the flowers that makes the Black Panther
Black Panther is there gonna be another
plot that is a great point if they
burned all the flowers that makes Black
Panther Black Panthers they're gonna be
another Black Panther it has to be that
flowers somewhere else right somewhat in
some weird cave somewhere as if that was
the case they wouldn't have to steal one
so yeah this might be the last
generation of black panther you know my
big problem with Black Panther was its
predict ality instead of a particulate
II yeah as soon as like stuff started
happening I could piece together what
was happening in my mind I know I should
avoid that one I'm watching tomorrow the
movie but I think that this MCM movie
just didn't and just lacked the twists
and stuff that I expected for
blockbusters like this that said I love
this movie but my big problem was that
it was easily predictable I could easily
see what was coming
in the future appreciate the comment
predictability is the word you're
looking for but I totally get where
you're coming from
in your defense my man you know how many
times I have filmed the review not even
noticed I've said the wrong word or
mispronounced a word that I'm editing
and hours later I'm like that is not the
word gonna have to turn on all the
filming equipment just to say the word
correctly in the sentence however in
terms of predictability your big movie
fan aren't you I can tell because you
have seen too much you've seen so many
movies you've seen it all you can kind
of see where the path is going I've been
there too it's a burden among we movie
fans sing Black Panther for the second
time it just confirms what I thought
about it when I saw for the first time
which is it's an amazing movie not
perfect but it taught me something and
it's very different from other MCA
movies because of the message that was
put into this movie if we all can just
come together and work together we can
become a better nation we can become a
better world and kill more talk to tell
of that and I feel like this movie needs
to be heard I agree there are two kinds
of blockbusters out there they're the
blockbusters that are just for fun
entertainment and they're blockbusters
that are there for fun entertainment but
they leave you with something you walk
away with something to ponder Black
Panther was one of those and it really
hits at home in that first end credits
scene where two challahs talking to the
UN he's like okay here we are we all
just come together things will be better
our way thus far isn't really working
kill mongers white isn't working there's
another one I'm glad this was a movie
that let you me a lot of people walk
away with something deeper I love this
movie great world building great
characters great score I'm in love with
a coy way now my only gripe sar with
some pacing issues and I'm not a huge
fan of a lot of the action scenes but
besides that perfect film my question to
you my friend what do you think they're
gonna do with the inevitable sequel love
to catch a movie with you sometime man
just so you know watching a movie with
me is the most boring experience up when
I watch a movie I just pay attention to
the movie I don't talk in a movie I
apparently make any sounds in the movie
I will laugh you might as well watch a
movie next to an empty chair I'm just
saying it's the same effect what are
they gonna do for the sequel that's a
good question the sequel should
springboard off of what the previous
movie established where the previous
movie left off only thing is there is
infinity war in between there so are
they gonna springboard off of where
infinity war was they're gonna
springboard off of where this was either
it should have something to do with
opening their country to the rest of the
world the truth of their country to the
rest of the world
I feel like inevitably the governments
of the world will want to weaponize the
wakandan tax they're gonna be like a
Loki invaded this Thanos guy was worse
we have to make better weapons how can
we make better weapons look at that what
kind of place sure we can weaponize
their attack then what Kahn just
probably not going to want to there's
gonna be some conflict there really is
but iron men did also he was like I am
Iron Man it came out of his Iron Man
closet and everyone was like okay give
us your tech it was like no Avengers did
this like Avengers establish the fact
that they were making weapons because of
the incidents and Thor won like uh gods
are real I guess we have to make better
weapons it's actually what vulture was
doing his spider-man homecoming also
making weapons out of new tech so really
the weaponization of tech has been a
theme it's been the theme among the
Marvel Cinematic Universe since it
started it's actually been a theme in
cinema forever if you seem 2001 in space
honestly the first 20 minutes of that
movie illustrates that when early man
found technology they weaponized said
technology so I can see it going that
route which usually when i theorize
about movies and shows never goes that
way so it probably won't dude this movie
was false advertisement it should have
been called kill monger featuring Black
Panther because he completely stole the
show I mean I knew Michael B
Jordan was gonna be good no doubt but
the way he was written the way and the
way he was portrayed on screen the way
Michael B Jordan brought this character
to life it was fantastic everything
about this movie was great but Wow
all hail king kill monger Michael B
Jordan does without a doubt a
spectacular job in stem we all know that
and he gives amazing dialogue and
amazing just depths of this character
that we end up ruining for him in a way
one question I do have though is what if
he didn't die in this film do you think
that he'll be a low-key type antagonist
protagonist and he might be turned to
the good side or do you think he might
just stick to his evil ways it's kind of
hard to tell put those two together
because I feel like they work in tandem
like they're a good pair you two are a
good pair you never met but you are in
terms of your one comment anyway lotta
love for kill monger I do agree now to
the question if he didn't die would he
somehow turn to the good side or maybe
be an antihero later on like Loki it
really speaks volumes for
kill monger in the sense that he was
more than happy he would rather die than
go to jail it would defeat kill mongers
ideology to send him to prison or
capture and it would definitely slap his
character in the face to have him
somehow become some antihero and and
play nice with the good guys at one
point even if it is to go against a
greater evil the best ending for him was
to die in this movie list now that I
said that I feel like they're gonna
bring him back to life now totally make
me eat my words if kill monger ever
comes back to life I can see myself
rolling with it for entertainments sake
but I can't see myself going back on the
phrase I speak now which is kill monger
dying in black panther was the cleanest
end for kill mongers character one of
the really cool things about black
panther to me was it actually made me
emotional and I actually teared up when
Michael B Jordans character died
usually when a villain dies in a movie
I'm like ya die piece of or
hope you burn in hell
but no I actually sympathized with him
very deeply and I wanted to ask you
Jeremy has any film ever made you cry to
the villain death that is actually a
tough one villains that I have I haven't
I don't think I've shed actual tears for
the passing of a villain there are
villains that I can see where they're
coming for like you look at magneto was
the earliest example I was like oh my
gosh like I always saw magneto I was
like I am Magneto master of magnets from
the arcade game and you have to beat me
then I saw the first x-men movie by
Bryan Singer and I was like he's even
more complex than that he's just a dude
who saw the turning of the tide and a
very familiar tide that he had already
seen in his childhood he's like we're
not doing that again
no empathizing with villains it's
something that happens more often in
videogames for me then movies probably
because videogames have more time to
flush out the villains one that I can
just think about the top of my head is
Magus from Chrono Trigger spoilers for
Chrono Trigger if you haven't played
Chrono Trigger ponies when you see his
story come full circle after Zeile Falls
you're like
I get you and damn your story is a
really sad one some will argue mega
isn't actually the villainville
I would argue he is a villain he's just
not vvill and he's not la voz you don't
think he's a villain ask Glen frog I'm
sure he'd say otherwise all depends
perspective so I'll say that's my answer
Magus from Chrono Trigger so a question
has come into my head regarding Black
Panther which is that if what Condor was
like isolated and separate from the
entire world for like centuries or
whatever like they say at the beginning
of the movie were they completely and
totally like away from Hydra or shield
or anything like how come Hydra didn't
know anything about this place but
someone like ulysses klaw know about
this place so what would Hydra have done
if they knew about I think that's kind
of an interesting question to answer
that is the question is all this time
anytime there's just the super hidden
thing of some weird arms dealer
archaeologist is like I know everything
about that how did that knowledge pass
your desk that's the weird question I
imagine he's sold from a guy who bought
from a guy who knew a guy who knew
someone's best friend sisters boyfriends
brother's girlfriends heard from this
guy that Ferris passed out of 31 flavors
last night and somehow ran across
Wakanda and that is somehow knowledge
got back to ulysses klaw and again that
would leave a long trail like enough
people at that point would know about
what kondo word would spread how did he
find out I don't know
whereas Hydra and shield I can see the
fact that they don't know because no one
in Wakanda has social media you imagine
that like all these selfies all click so
I was like what's that background what's
that city what's that mountain so now
whenever Conda can really have social
media I feel like they're just off the
grid entirely I suppose that what help
and their facade other world leaders
could be like you believe they don't
even have Instagram over there in their
technologically advanced country however
if anyone from Hydra had strolled into
Wakanda in their capital city they get
their balls kicked in Wakanda hasn't
rounded all right so that's where I'm
gonna end this video thank you all for
the reactions I got a lot of reactions
know a lot of you didn't see your
reactions on here this is actually of
the ones I whittled down to this is
actually half of them but as this videos
running long and you know I hate long
videos I'm gonna cut it off here this is
a good first presentation whether or not
this happens more in the future that
really largely depends on you guys if
you like it I'd like to do it again if
you don't like it no sense to do is them
you don't like so if you like this
segment you want to see more you wanna
see the other
half of the Black Panther reaction keep
this around out there get the video some
love helps me out plus you know feels
good if people lack my you don't
know what I'm talking about what star
dust is as a link below you can download
the star dust app follow me on the
Stardust app once in a while say hey
I'll do these Stardust reactions when
you tag me and it was fine in 30-second
reviews you too can review a movie right
so this episode this thing this
interaction I'm doing what do you think
about this video whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]